we have to go back the who Williams
stamps cherry was at the age of twenty
he does head out for Africa against
everybody's advice who said you're gonna
die over there
he went into into Africa in the 1889 and
went further than the Congo then an a
the white man had never gone thirty
thousand miles over two trips into the
Congo my grandfather was an African
Explorer at the age of twenty he wasn't
talked about much you know it was kind
of like you know there's the Tusk
grandfather shot that and that was it as
a kid they were just under my bed and
they're too heavy for our kid to pull
around but when he had when he got about
we had a like the little tribute here
and type of thing we had for grandfather
this was a young a young man who when he
was a young boy had read the stories of
henry morton stanley and david
livingstone his background included
floating down the Missouri River on a
raft
much like the Huckleberry Finn stories
of Mark Twain he was a boy an American
boy of the land he was educated and
trained in mechanical arts and as a
mechanic and a machinist his forte was
steam engines he knew had a tear apart
steam engines rebuild him out of nothing
most the people who ran into along the
way basically popped his blooming real
fast and said you're gonna die because
he had to fit you at malaria you had the
the lack of knowledge of the the area
and he just but he persevered William
stamps Jerry spent a number of years in
this heart of darkness this area of the
continent of Africa that had no name at
the time and this area is today called
the Central African Republic he was like
half of the end of one world and half of
the new world coming in half old world
pioneer and Explorer and hunter half new
world businessman entrepreneur he left
the boy of pension for hunting animals
and floating down rivers on rafts and
living off of the land and took a very
serious look of what destiny had given
him which was an opportunity to study a
continent and its people its rivers its
lands its wildlife the powers that were
there the colonization the great
scramble of carving up the land and he
wrote about it and he talked about it
until the world changed and no one was
much interested in any of that anymore
the book he had hoped to write never got
written he had his way of doing things
and publishers had their way of doing
things and when push came to shove he
just said back with it I don't need it
I've been there I've done it grandfather
I think just decided well I got a family
now there's not a big interest in Africa
right now the story just got lost and I
think grandfather just lost maybe maybe
the the enthusiasm to get it done it's a
sad thing when you think of someone that
had such an incredible life because he
could have been literally forgotten from
history and it would've been a shame
because he made history without a doubt
[Music]
Oh